hey what is up guys I'm kV HD here and
yeah I know what you're thinking most
people don't even have Android M yet and
yet we're already getting a preview of
the next version yup it's earlier than
normal this year before Google i/o and
everything and it's loaded on this Nexus
6p
so let's take a look at the best new
features in Android n so it's going to
be a lot of smaller stuff first of all
there's no version number that I can see
but it feels like this is going to be
something like Android 6.1 a lot of what
you'll see here is redesigns so number
one a redesigned Settings app so you can
see it looks pretty similar to the
marshmallow Settings app but in each
category it's starting to take advantage
of the larger screens these phones have
and it's showing you a little
information inside it before you have to
click it so with battery without
clicking it tells you how much battery
you have left storage tells you how much
space you have open Wi-Fi and bluetooth
tell you what you're connected to before
you even open the settings so that's
pretty cool and then you have when you
do click into a setting you get a new
option which is a swipe outside menu
with links to all the other settings so
you can use this bar to sort of navigate
between sub menus if you know where you
want to go and it's pretty quick I don't
know if this actually saves any steps as
far as the number of clicks but it works
well and you can kind of memorize where
your most settings are on the list so
you can definitely get to them pretty
quickly this way I actually like the way
it looks in landscape I don't use my
phone and landscape that much but it
looks like the settings from Android
Honeycomb back in the old tablet days
taking advantage of the bigger screen
alright number two is redesigned
notifications so you can see your
notifications are a bit wider now they
take up the whole width of the display
and they show a lot more information now
again really taking advantage of the
bigger high res displays we have and you
can tap the little down arrow to expand
or contract notifications or you can
stick to the two-finger drag which is a
lot easier to get that more information
and then some apps like first party apps
like Gmail well let you expand so much
that you can actually take individual
action on each item so notifications are
bundled as they come in but once you
expand it you can archive emails like
one by one or pick a single email to
take an action on like a reply and I
think more apps will start to pick this
up too so if you get like three Twitter
notifications you can choose what to do
with
one after you expand so I like this and
you also now have a half swipe over to
get to notification settings for that
app I kind of liked the long press
better but that's how you do it now and
some apps will support inline replies in
the notifications so like hangouts for
example the new hangouts app will let
you reply to a message without ever
leaving the notification panel and then
get back to what you were doing again a
lot of this stuff is new functionality
to take advantage of your bigger screens
I like it so number three is redesigned
quick settings up top this is something
we've seen in skinned versions of
Android before actually so HTC Sense
TouchWiz but now you can just pull down
once and have these quick toggles to
frequently use functions like Wi-Fi or
Bluetooth or your flashlight or whatever
when you pull down again that's when you
get to your quick settings that you're
familiar with with the bigger panel and
it's paginate it so you can swipe across
between screens as many as you want here
and there's also a new edit button right
up front so you can go in there and move
stuff around move stuff in move stuff
out move stuff into the top five so that
it becomes a quick setting etc so this
is classic Android full on customization
fun you can really set the most-used
functions right up top to be at your
fingertips number four is a redesigned
multitasking so this is definitely my
new favorite change in Android n so
right off the bat the multitasking cards
are way bigger so lets you see more info
in your last used app on the screen
which is pretty cool and then when
you're in an app and you hit the
multitasking button it brings the app
you're in way down to the bottom because
you don't want to go back into that same
app I've done up accident a lot so now
when you hit the button it just gets out
the way and shows you a big card of your
second-to-last most used app so now what
it gets right is one of my favorite
additions which is the double tap it
kind of acts like a quick app switcher
and swaps back with your most recently
used app I think it's awesome it's handy
for quick copy paste stuff we're just
going back and forth between two apps
you use a lot like Twitter and reddit
and back to Twitter whatever you're
doing is pretty handy and then new to
stock Android we now have split-screen
multitasking so when you're in an app
you hold the multitasking button then
pick another app and then you're in and
this is awesome
we again used to only see this in skins
but now you can grab the bar in the
middle and resize the multi
testing windows or use the bar to close
one out entirely I got to say for a
Developer Preview this is really smooth
like I didn't expect it to be this good
at all but it's nice and stable and it
works works in landscape too so I'm
hoping I'm hoping that a bunch of apps
now that this is in the Developer
Preview will quickly support this and a
few months down the road so we get this
new version early app developers get to
build it in and then when the new
version of Android comes out like a new
Nexus almost everyone's apps already
works with split-screen
all right number five last but not least
is the dark mode it was kind of buried
in the last Android M Developer Preview
but again we have a functional night
mode in Android which essentially
reverses the colors in a major core apps
like settings to be dark behind the
green which can be useful if you're
using your phone at night or at some
place where you don't want it to blast
light everywhere it still is in system
tuner so you don't exactly have it at
your fingertips but you do get to dig in
and mess around with it and it even has
a feature to automatically turn on at
sunset kind of like the night mode in
Google Maps nice so there you have it if
there's a bunch of other little stuff
here and there like an improved doze
that should even work to help save
battery life when the phone is in your
pocket and there's also a data saver
mode so when you just know you're going
to run out of data you can kind of keep
your phone in check there but that's the
best of what's new and Android n so far
again it's just a Developer Preview
number one so more changes and features
will be added before the final version
this summer yes the app drawer is still
here
looks like we're keeping that but let me
know what you think what's your favorite
new item personally I'm all about that
DoubleTap app switcher but that's just
me thanks for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace